[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
私は
8新宿
少年院やゲーム所を出られた方の
事実を支援をしています
8新宿という塾長
両親塾の塾長しております
なぜ部が少年やゲームショウでられた方の
支援をしているかを少しお話しさせて
いただきます
私は大阪市城東区というところで生まれ
まして現在50歳です
母は楽しまの薩摩川内というところで
生まれまして
二十歳の時に大阪に出てきて
父お願い僕を黒会計の長男として産んで
くれました
母は僕の事を本当に愛して可愛がってくれ
ました
やりたいこともやらせてくれました
そんな母はですね少しだけ豹変する時期が
ありました
駄文ですね
お父さんの
女性関係だとは思うんですけど
それですねイライラしてなのかどうか
わからないんですけど今まで見たことない
要素
時にはですねこう僕を高くふりをしてです
ね僕が何かをしようとするとその行いを
止めようとしました
僕はその母の代わり切った
形相に
よく
寂しくて
布団の中に泣いていたのも今でもよく覚え
ています
そんな中で
地域はもう家に帰ってこなくなり離婚する
ことになりました
母は
昼はアート夜は内職して僕たち兄弟を養っ
てくれました
はぁが
その頃からですね
イライラしたりとか僕たちに当たってくる
ことはなくなりました
その中でまた僕は母が優しい愛に包まれ
ながら
楽しい小学生時代を過ごすんですが
僕はその母の愛とは
反対にですね
恥ずかしいんですけどあの不良少年にに
なってしまいまして
中学三年生宮司がですねもうこんな感じに
なってしまいました
夜は妄想
セット気に食わないことがあればケンカ
本当にとんでもない若者でした
社会に出てからも仕事まともにできず
最悪の方々に行きます
防具ボール普段
学生際4を
ボール普段を止めるために小指を自らちー
りました
傷害事件を起こして社会人なのに逮捕され
そのまま
裏社会に身を置いていたときもありました
そんな部分に
転機が訪れたのは第1回目の天気ですね
頭に
付き合っていた彼女を8歳年下19歳でし
た
妊娠させてしまいました
さすがに僕も責任を取らないといけないと
思っている
決行することに決めました
その時の子供が現在22歳大学4年生に
なっています
それから2年後に
経営者になりました
経営者になった目的はお金儲けがしたかっ
ただけです
人に使われるのが嫌だったんです
たったそれだけの個人的な利己的な理由で
会社を興しました
それがですね
美容室を経営したんですけど大成功して
しまうんですね
1号店3号店
フタ付10人20人
売り上げもどんどん伸びる
お金もどんどん入ってくる
僕みたいな
バカがですねこういう人生を
楽して成功してしまうとどういうことに
なるかというと
病にかかってしまうんですね
どういう病かというと
傲慢と言う名の病です
何でも自分でできるとお金が全てやると
このボールは本当に思っていました
その頃の僕です
35歳です
この傲慢極まりない35歳の僕の考え方へ
方を変えざる得ない出来事が起きます
一方の電話が鳴りました電話を取りました
あなたのお母さんの意識がなくなったので
今すぐ病院に来てくださいと言われます
僕は何のことか分からず慌てて病院に
向かいました
すると集中治療室に僕の側が横たわってい
僕が泣こうが
は目以降がー
今までの親子を
はみょうが
おかんはピクリと動きません
そのまま2顔
元は一度も
4覚ますことなく
平成18年12月30日
移民しました
59歳のを重ね
なくなりました
僕は
その時あまりの突然の出来事と
今までの自分の行いが無さげないしていっ
申し上げなくてー
おかんに会いたくて
ご飯も食べれなくなりました1ヶ月なら
切らせました
毎日泣いていました
でもお金は返ってこないです
保管は生き返らないです
そんなに僕ふと思いました
よう考えたらお母んこんな俺を最後まで
愛してくれていつも俺のこと心配してくれ
てたなって
そんなを版が今の俺の姿見たら絶対悲しみ
や労使喜んでフレンやろうと思いました
じゃあ残りの人生ぐらいはおかんに
恥ずかしくない引けた
オカンが
幼児がんばったなあって言ってもらえない
方をしようとこの時に初めて
決意しました
でもぼくほんま日頭悪いんでどうやって
変わったらいいかわからないんですよね
でもなんでもいいばと思っていって思う
こと何でもやりました
グッズ揃えました
gomi 拾いました
便所掃除もしました
読んだことない本も読みました
経営の勉強会であったりとか人間道を
学べる塾にも入りました
そして
僕の
大きく変える
店名のれ合いになる職親プロジェクト
うほっそ分
のメンバーとして
参加することもできました
触診ボリューム度に入って約も9年が経ち
ます
今まで50人近くの若者と売れ行ってき
ました
皆さん
少年院出院者
どういうイメージありますか
薩田した人
内部を振り回した人暴力団関係者
僕みたいに強い兄ちゃん
僕も
うみたいな兄ちゃんが来ると思ってました
ん
でもですね両親軸には
そんな強い兄ちゃんは来ませんでした
どういう子が来たかと思いますか
子供の頃に
虐待や育児放棄を受けて
自分の居場所がなかったりとか
生きる希望がなかったり夢がなかったり
明日死にたいと思ったりとか
自分の体にリストパッドを
何本もするんですねを行くは100本入り
をしてました
僕はその姿を見て衝撃でした
ボクらの時代に隊員に暴力振るう
若者いわゆるヤンキーはたくさんいました
けど
自分の体を傷つけたりとか
少年を出たくないとか知りたいという若者
は少なくども僕がふりをしてる時になり
ませんでした
8新宿に来た子どもたちの共通点を
全員虐待経験者でやり
多くが児童養護施設出身者でありそして
大人や社会に振り回されて自分だけが少年
いってしまうてしまった子どもたちです
これはぼくが生まれた頃の写真です
皆さん
生まれた時の赤ちゃんで悪い子っているん
でしょうか
自尊心が低く
夢や希望をやりたいことがない
幼稚園人っているんでしょうか
僕はいないと思います
みんな真っ白人生向きで可能性の塊で
生まれてくると思います
そんな時に
熱湯を掛けられたりとか
1週間ご飯浮かれたりとか
やるほどすべて否定されたりと思う
毎日殴られたりとか首を絞められたりとか
皆さんどうでしょうか
実際自分が子供の時期にそういうことをさ
れたらどんな気持ちになるでしょうか
夢や希望を持てるでしょうか
m 君
この手は
猫が220匹ます
男の子が飼いたいです
この子も凶悪犯罪をして少年に入りました
僕は少年院でこの子と出会いました
この子は小学校1年生から中学1年生まで
お母さんに学校以外の会食は外出は禁止
宿題や課題ができないと毎日殴られ
ひどい的には包丁を突きつけられたことも
何回もあるらしいです
そんなカレーはですね僕に衝撃なことを本
的にいいましていっ
中学1年生の時そのハワイは癌で死んだ
嬉しくて嬉しくて
笑いをこらえるの必死あったって言ったん
ですね
13歳の子供が命の根源である自分の母
自分の母が死んだ時に笑いをこらえるの
必死やったって言ったんですよ気に入っ
635歳でお母さんなくなりましたん
7蹴らせました今でも彼のことを思い出し
たら波などに出てきますお金がだしておか
ん大変たらいくら出してもを簡単痛いです
じゃあ
m 君は
両親がないんでしょうか
本当に悪なんでしょうか
僕は
お母さんの愛が欲しかったよと思います
一人で寂しかったようなと思います
いろんな人に誰かに助けてほしかったなと
思います
でもみっちゃんを助ける人は誰もいません
でした一人で後続行ったんです
そんな彼は今も社会に適応できず
依存身を低く
生きづらい人生を歩んでいます
もう1人紹介させてください
彼女は現在21歳
二十歳の時に僕が養女にしました
現在は僕が運営しているおせっかいな
居酒屋言いまで女将をしております
彼女であったら17歳少年でした
彼女
子供のゴリコロニー
母親や
霧の時期
社会に
振り回された子どもの1人です
居場所がなく
毎日死にたい
助けてといつも心の中で叫んでいたそう
です
そんな彼に彼女が
僕に合った時にこう言いました
私の人生は大人ウンドレイヤー
楽しいことで打ったらおっちゃん騙すこと
ぐらいかな
うがその言葉を聞いた時にこう言いました
確かにそうかもしれん
お前が今まで見てきた世界は面白くない夢
も希望もない世界かもしれない
でもな
俺も35歳から生き方変えて考え方開たら
今まで見たことない人
今まで知らなかった仕事を世の中にこんな
人がいでるんやっていうのを初めて知った
んや自分がどれだけせないし家の中で着て
いきたいかって35歳のオレも出版やんだ
からな俺を前にこれからいろんな世界
いろんな人と会わせるから黙って俺につい
てきてくれと
それから僕は彼女が今まで体験したこと
ないことであったりとか
今まで出会ったことない音がかっこいい
生き方をしている大人
そのために時間を作って使えロートな
いろんな人たちに会ってもらいました
仕事もいろんな仕事をやってもらいました
仕事の楽しさも覚えてもらいました
を笑うようになりました
そして彼女は2年前にお母さんになりまし
た
今現在
1歳9ヶ月になります
おなかの中にも
9ヶ月の赤ちゃんがいまや取っています
皆さんどうですかこの子は
夢も希望もない大人になるでしょうか
寂しい
少年時代を過ごすでしょうか
僕は絶対ないと思います
なぜかというとこの母親の愛に包まれ
母親ができないことを僕たち血のつながら
ない家族仲間がですねみんなでサポート
するんですよ
なので
この子が
人を殺めたり人を傷つけたりとか夢も希望
のないような大人になることは絶対にない
と僕は確信しています
僕たちさんにのちがいってなんですかねぇ
僕はオカンから無償内容もらいました
祖父母や
周りの人にいっぱい助けてもらいました一
杯サポートしてもらいました
なので僕はいつでもチャレンジする力強さ
があります道にはそれてしまいましたが
じゃあ
皆さんどうでしょうか
子供を虐待しているお母さんもお父さんも
本当に悪い人でしょうか
寂しいんじゃないでしょうか
自分ももしだしたら愛を受けなかったん
じゃないでしょうか
もしかしたら経済的にかなりビズ待ってる
んじゃないでしょうか
今の日本で子育てがしやすい社会でしょう
か
虐待してしまう人も何かの理由があると
思いますそれをみんなでサポートしていけ
ば
僕は虐待だけじゃなくて
自殺も犯罪もそれこそ戦争でさえも争いで
さえも
名倉の社会
そのための一歩がお母さんの笑顔だと
王様になりました
お母さんが払っていうと子供は幸せなん
ですね
午後は本当に裕福ではなかったですけど
本当に幸せな表彰旗を過ごさせていただき
ました
お母さん9
溢れて育てられた子供の子は命を尊び
女性や女ログを大事にするお父さんになり
ます
母の愛を無性に受けた女の子は
自分のこのままにも愛をちゃんと伝えて
日本のお母さん
なってくれると思います
キング牧師も言われています
皆さんどうですか
社会本題に目を伏せ出ませんか
知らないふりをしていませんか自分には
関係のないことだと思ってませんか
追加4つながっていますよ
キング大串も
前任の沈黙と無関心が最大の問題だと言っ
てます僕も本当にそうだと思います
だから僕は
悪もでも
炙りんでもないただ無関心でいうか知ら
ない大人たちにもみんなで巻き込めるよう
にあーでしゅマニー2年前に無農薬の農園
を開きました両親ファームと言います
ここで
今までそういうことを知らなかった人
もっと社会に貢献したいと幸せになれた
お母さんお父さん
巻き込んで行こうと思っています
皆さんもぜひ仲間になっていただきたい
です
最後になります
世界平和はおかん
お母さんの幸せから始まる
僕は今確信しています
お母さん
生命の根源であるお母さんお母さんから
生まれてきてない人は誰一人いないはず
です
その命の根源であるおかあさんがいつも
笑顔で
いつも子どもと楽しく過ごせる社会を一緒
にみんなで作っていけたら
いつかはその子どもたちが世界の平和を
つくってくれるんじゃないかなと思います
今日は僕の話を聞いていただき本当に
ありがとうございましたこれからもどうぞ
よろしくお願いします
[拍手]